round seven of the US chess  championships were the nation's elite  players battle it was the day after the  rest day and the leaders return  refreshed and ready to get out in their  quest for the title 17 year old Jennifer  you defeated 2017 champion Sabina Pfizer  but a nosotros key crushed her longtime  rival arena crush to stay within  fighting distance of the lead Hikaru  Nakamura kept his lead with a win  against version of Kobe on but Fabiano  Caruana won again to keep up the  pressure with just four rounds to go  they are rounding the bend with every  game now on a Razors Edge exciting round  eight action coming up  [Music]